[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este
es un magazine informativo dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es amal
benotman y estos son los titulares el 25
de marzo finalizó en dakar senegal el
foro mundial del agua celebrado por
primera vez en un país de áfrica
subshariana la gestión de este recurso
plantea un reto importante para casi la
totalidad de los países del continente
tenemos análisis el ciclista eritreo
binyam firme consiguió la victoria más
importante de un corredor africano en
ciclismo nuestro especialista en
deportes nos comentará este logro
monumental
e iremos a sudáfrica a conocer la sirena
negra sand y el globo es la primera
instructora en negra de buceo en
sudáfrica país donde las playas estaban
prohibidas para las personas de su
comunidad
del 21 al 25 de marzo se celebró en
dakar la capital senegalesa el noveno
foro mundial del agua miles de
participantes de todo el mundo entre
ellos varios ministros y jefes de estado
se reunieron para buscar respuestas a
los retos que plantea la gestión de los
recursos hídricos
organizado cada tres años es la primera
vez que el foro se celebra en el áfrica
subsahariana donde el 40 por ciento de
la población no tiene acceso a los
servicios básicos de agua según la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económicos que además se
estima que en 2050 más de 162 millones
de personas residentes en las zonas
urbanas del continente se enfrentarán a
la escasez permanente del agua
preguntamos como wang y especialista en
recursos hídricos y saneamiento cuáles
son los retos más importantes a los que
se enfrentan los países africanos más
afectados por este problema con su
repartición áfrica frasco tú le piso
empezaré diciendo que en áfrica casi
todos los países están preocupados por
la cuestión del agua debido a la
desigualdad distribución geográfica de
los recursos hídricos disponibles en el
continente hay una segunda razón a este
problema y es que el alto índice de
crecimiento de la población y la rápida
urbanización llevan a una demanda de
agua cada vez mayor pero también a
problemas de degradación de este recurso
con su contaminación de la london
pulsión andalucía liotta socio de la cea
reputarlo en cuanto a los retos hay que
garantizar el acceso al agua potable a
casi 400 millones de habitantes de los
1.300 millones que viven actualmente en
áfrica hay que garantizar también el
acceso al saneamiento básico a casi 800
millones de habitantes sin olvidar la
cuestión del refuerzo de la resiliencia
climática y la necesidad de movilizar
una financiación importante de 40 mil
millones de dólares anualmente para
poder reducir la brecha en términos de
inversión e infraestructuras para el
agua en áfrica
y por último como one hielos hablo de
los principales compromisos adoptados
por el foro de dakar
el foro de dakar finalizó como una serie
de compromisos y esperanzas entre las
que destaca la declaración del llamado
judío de dakar 2022 para garantizar la
seguridad del agua y el saneamiento para
la paz y el desarrollo en áfrica basado
en una serie de medidas
se decidió entre varias cosas crear un
panel internacional de alto nivel para
desarrollar formas concretas de
movilizar 30.000 millones de dólares
cada año hasta 2030 para reducir el
déficit de inversión en agua en áfrica
las perspectivas parecen buenas pero es
necesario trabajar juntos para que los
resultados de este foro se tengan en
cuenta en las decisiones y resoluciones
que se adopten en la próxima conferencia
de las naciones unidas sobre el agua que
tendrá lugar en marzo de 2000 23 en
nueva york' nosotros vino solo de más de
1000 'mentira' alivio
y cabe mencionar que como en cada
edición se organizó paralelamente un
foro alternativo del agua por parte de
la sociedad civil para dar dos a quienes
no pueden pagar las costosas cuotas de
entrada al evento oficial si bien el
derecho al agua está reconocido desde
2010 por las naciones unidas el foro
alternativo a esta campaña para que los
países no inscriban en sus
constituciones y que las medidas
adoptadas sean vinculantes
continuamos con estas impresionantes
imágenes son vistas aéreas filmadas de
noche y que muestran la capital de
nigeria lagos sumida en la oscuridad
total por falta de electricidad en las
últimas semanas el colapso de la red
eléctrica combinado con un aumento
global de los precios del petróleo
debido a la guerra en ucrania ha unido
al país en una grave crisis energética
que en consecuencia está afectando
gravemente a su economía
el presidente mohammadu buhari se
disculpó por la situación pero de un año
de las elecciones presidenciales la
oposición ha advertido que la crisis
podría provocar masivas protestas
populares
pasamos ahora a la actualidad deportiva
el ciclista eritreo viviam firme ganó el
27 de marzo la gante wevelgem
una carrera profesional de ciclismo
disputada cada año en bélgica es la
primera vez que un corredor subsahariano
se impone una clásica de ciclismo
bini como se le conoce confirmó las
esperanzas depositadas en él desde que
empezó a practicar el ciclismo
rodrigo se dañó especialista en deportes
para france24 nos comentó este logro
excepcional
un nombre destaca entre las promesas
futuras y ya presentes del pelotón
ciclista mundial binjiang irma y high
look ciclista eritreo de 21 años plata
en el mundial sub-23 en 2021 y reciente
ganador de la cante bebé en una de las
carreras más importantes del calendario
primaveral europeo de categoría world
tour la máxima del ciclismo y enmarcada
dentro de las grandes citas sobre
adoquines del centro de europa nunca
antes un ciclista africano había ganado
una prueba de este tipo y nunca antes un
eritreo había ganado una prueba del
world tour es increíble asombroso afirmo
hailu tras su victoria y no es para
menos pues alzó los brazos frente a
muchos de los grandes especialistas en
este tipo de pruebas de un solo día en
las que hasta ahora no había destacado
ningún ciclista africano un hito en un
deporte reticente a salir de las
fronteras europeas y aquí la clave
futura de todo esto el eritreo puede ser
sólo la punta de lanza de un ciclismo
africano en crecimiento con una fecha
marcada en el calendario
de ciclismo de 2025 que a inicios de año
fue adjudicado a ruanda un país que
desde hace años se ha destacado como una
ciclista africana gracias a su ya famoso
tour de ruanda que cada año deja
estampas de cientos de aficionados
apoyando a los ciclistas de todo el
mundo en las carreteras ruandesas kigali
la capital del país será sin duda una
gran plataforma para que más ciclistas
africanos sigan el camino que está
marcando binjiang irma y jairo
vamos ahora a costa de marfil donde un
grupo de jóvenes mezcla la danza
contemporánea con la tradicional y con
el teatro una combinación de artes
escénicas con un fuerte resultado de
crítica social
cuando alexandre wilfred agua conocido
como speed world creó el grupo de baile
los real boys nunca imaginó que un día
se presentarían en uno de los mayores
eventos culturales de áfrica conformado
por 10 jóvenes de entre 18 y 32 años el
grupo tuvo su mayor desempeño hasta la
fecha en el mercado de las artes
escénicas de abiyán conocido como el
masa y una de las exhibiciones más
antiguas y prestigiosas del continente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
por supuesto más a es la mayor
oportunidad que hemos tenido desde el
inicio del grupo
y realmente nos va a ayudar a darnos a
conocer internacionalmente porque sé que
por la gracia de dios los que vengan a
ver el espectáculo hablarán de nosotros
en otros lugares así que es una vitrina
realmente importante
pero el objetivo del grupo es sobre todo
social su espectáculo gueto se inspira
en las experiencias cotidianas de los
jóvenes de los barrios difíciles y
aborda la violencia y los estragos que
causa el consumo de drogas
en este espectáculo en un mensaje muy
bueno porque en estos momentos en áfrica
los jóvenes están muy metidos en el
alcohol y el tabaco y eso es lo que
llamamos básicamente el ghetto que lleva
mucha violencia y agresividad así que
denunciar este comportamiento creo que
es un muy buen mensaje para el
continente
la industria del arte y de la cultura
está en auge en costa de márfil en la
última década muchos grupos de danza han
obtenido un reconocimiento internacional
y muchos jóvenes marfileños ven en la
danza una oportunidad de expresarse y de
ganarse la vida
en sudáfrica hasta el final de la parte
de las playas estaban prohibidas a las
personas negras pero hoy una mujer se
convirtió en la primera y única
instructora negra de buceo del país
sandy le lobos lanzó su fundación
llamada la sirena negra para transmitir
su amor del océano a las nuevas
generaciones y animarlas así a
preservarlo
se la conoce como la sirena negra sandy
y puede encender hasta 34 metros durante
4 minutos en respirar
de pekín en aguas aguas al principio
tenía miedo no me he criado cerca del
mar recuerdo que me quedaba atascada a
23 metros no porque no pudiera respirar
sino porque estaba aterrorizada por
todas las historias que había oído de
pequeñas por una web
sin embargo se convirtió en la primera
instructora de buceo negra hace 20 años
ni siquiera imaginaba que esta profesión
existiera
estos mares no siempre han sido
accesibles a todas las comunidades la
historia de nuestro país es dolorosa el
mundo marino es muy nuevo para las
comunidades negras es un nuevo espacio
para explorar y conocer tandil vive
ahora en ciudad del cabo pero es
originaria de su gueto lejos de la costa
y de niña solo fue al mar una vez
lo que es una locura es que cuando
éramos pequeños y nada vamos nadie
pensaba realmente en la vida bajo el
agua no sabíamos nada por eso todo el
mundo me preguntaba por qué haces esas
cosas que hacen los blancos
debido a que el bajo la parte de estas
playas estaban reservadas a las
comunidades blancas tandil se propuso
llevar el océano a todos los niños
sudafricanos
había soñado alguna vez en el mar y de
esa manera a través de su organización
llamada la sirena negra santi le enseña
a los niños de todas las comunidades el
mundo marino para que aprendan a amar y
proteger los océanos al feliz verdad
creo que hay que concientizar y es
importante si queremos salvar los
océanos todo el mundo tiene que
involucrarse y aquí hay que tener mucho
cuidado
con vamos a poner la estrella de mar en
su sitio ahí está hermoso
a más ya no significa ya no sé ni yo más
duro es un género musical nacido hace
algunos años en los barrios sudafricanos
marginados y que hoy se oye en todas
partes del país en los autos en la calle
en las tiendas este género está además
conquistando todo el continente y más
allá gracias en gran parte al
importantísimo papel de las redes
sociales para dar a conocer este estilo
de música alrededor del mundo con un
concierto de la artista camón fue la
apodada la reina de la mafia no cerramos
nuestro programa gracias por
acompañarnos y sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
no